[Music]
and I you know I've known you for a long
time I didn't know that you were into
social media are you are you that
interested in it well I kind of hate it
I I think it's awful and uh are you have
Twitter so that I can just tell people
when I'm you know what I want them to
buy with and give me money I don't care
people get mad at me cuz I don't follow
anybody zero people that I follow people
are like your arrogant prick like I get
really angry people get mad at you think
that really how dare you not follow up
but why do they care it doesn't it's
like a piece of cake going come on man
one's right here why aren't you eating
me like why did they do this [ __ ] I'm
sorry I'm tell on television but uh I
don't I think it's better I think that
you shouldn't just do everything that's
available to do isn't a good idea
there's a culture right now that as soon
as they hey you get to do that I'm gonna
do it there's no sort of like maybe
that's not just the constant nobody
takes in life unless it comes through
this yes like whenever I see a televised
event that's a huge like the the
Olympics Opening Ceremony or a Time
Square at midnight on New Year's Eve
everybody they see sees of people all
looking at it through their phone like
there's explosions and acrobats but
they're looking at it through a little
3-inch screen like I think if Jesus
comes back and starts telling everyone
everything
it'll just everybody's just gonna be
twittering and they won't I am Christ
and I have returned oh my god Jesus is
right in front of me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but this is I'm now going to impart to
you I have Twitpic of Jesus oh my god
it's trending
Jesus is trending right now okay you
just look at me for